[Music]
Christopher Reeve is paralyzed and
fighting for his life just like that
don't move Oh perfect it was much too
soon to say goodbye to Dana Reeve she
left behind the couple's son will who's
13 years old dear will I've got good
news and bad news I'll start with the
bad because you always need to know
exactly what's going on no matter what
that won't change by the way the bad
news is you're at the lowest point of
your life you're in a hospital room in
New York City and you've just said your
final goodbyes to mom you're 13 she's 44
lung cancer never smoked gone just like
dad who died a year and a half ago which
at the time was the lowest who had been
now you're at a new bottom and you're
terrified and confused and just so sad
but here's the good news
this is the low point there's nowhere to
go but up and that is exactly where
you're headed
you will always remember the good stuff
your pitching is really study rose dad
in the driveway teaching you how to ride
a bike just by telling you what to do
you trusting him so fully that you just
do it
mom's singing voice filling the air with
sweetness at home and in the car to
school how lucky are you that in her
final moments when she finally had to
accept that she was dying mom knew where
to put you
she signed you over to the poochie's
your next-door neighbor's your second
family and now your adoptive family
you'll move in with them and love them
as fiercely and fully as they love you
there will be times when you will feel
lost
you will feel insecure less about the
braces and bad haircut you have now and
more about the choices you make the
direction of your career missteps in
relationships and social settings but
don't worry you'll keep playing sports
and singing in musicals and you'll get
good grades and make great friends and
you'll feel encouraged supported and
loved
you love to write and it will be
essential at your dream job reporting
and anchoring at ESPN
this is SportsCenter right now I won't
read where you promised mom and dad you
would work one day when you get that
call you want to call them and tell them
the great news and of course you can't
but you know that they already know to
millions of people they embody love and
loyalty commitment and courage
perseverance and hope now some people
are able to accept living with a severe
disability I am NOT one of them you'll
make them proud by honoring your family
name not by using it for special
treatment
but by living a life worthy of its
legacy my dad knew that cures for spinal
cord injuries were inevitable some days
like when you join the board of the
Christopher and Dana Reeve Foundation
you'll feel like you're doing a great
job other times like when your work play
balance gets a little too skewed toward
fun or you're lazy or you're rude or
you're selfish you'll feel nothing but
shame it sounds simple and cliched but
just be you because you are what will
make mom and dad most proud every moment
you spent with them they were preparing
you for a life without them you have
their values and mom's eyes and dad's
smile I want you to know that we do not
have all of this figured out but you
know that in the years ahead you will
face no obstacle greater than the one
you are starting to overcome right now
and no matter which way your journey
leads mom and dad will be there with you
every step of the way
how lucky are you sincerely well so boys
mature and so likeable I remember when
his mom died thinking how unfair this is
to this little boy and to see how he's
turned out you know his parents must be
very proud what a beautiful beautiful
tribute to them as parents we all teach
our kids how to leave us and they had to
do it in a shorter time and with their
example to live up to he clearly is the
support group he's always had a line yes
yeah family the poochie's nicely done
we'll read that was beautiful
CBS this morning published a
best-selling book based on our note to
self series it's called note to self
inspiring words from inspiring people
it's on sale now the book is published
by Simon & Schuster a division of CBS